ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE- TO.
OPEN. W. READ A FEW COMMENTS AS
IS- USUAL DURING OUR- COVERT
PROTOCOL WERE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING- AND EVEN THOUGH THIS
IS THE LARGEST ROOM THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER WE ARE
PHYSICALLY DISTANT AS YOU CAN
SEE- WE DO HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
ALLOWED TO HAVE ONE MINUTE TO
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
GALLERY THEY CAN HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT THEY CAN ALSO CHOOSE TO
LEAVE ONCE. PUBLIC COMMENT HAS
BEEN MADE- ALL THE PANELISTS
APPEARING ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY- BECAUSE THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING MEMBERS
HAVE FOR MEMBERS WHO HAVE
REQUESTED IN ADVANCE MAY APPEAR
REMOTELY- WE ALSO WILL ALLOW
MEMBERS IN THE ROOM OBVIOUSLY
AND I WILL BE GOING TO QUITE
MEMBERS QUESTION ANSWERS AFTER
THAT THE PALACE OF SPOKEN THERE
WILL BE NO VOTE IN COMMITTEE
TODAY. WE ARE ALSO ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT- VIA TELEPHONE
IN THE PHONE NUMBERS.
877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
TH. PLEASE CALL THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO.
NINE NINE. AND TO JUST TO BE IN
TODAY'S HEARING COVERS THREE
BILLS. ONE IS S. B. NINETY FIVE
WHICH IS A MEASURE TO EXPAND
PAID SICK LEAVE IT AT. THE
EXPENSE OF BUILT UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
LAST YEAR WE'LL ALSO BE
DISCUSSING TO- OTHER- BUDGET
BILLS WHICH ARE AB EIGHTY THREE
IN AB EIGHTY EIGHT THESE ARE
ALL CLEAN UP BILLS FROM THE
EARLY ACTION ITEM. FROM A FEW
WEEKS AGO. SO MANY- SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPENING COMMENTS MY
VICE CHAIR SEEING NONE WE'RE
GOING TO GO STRAIGHT TO OUR-
HYSTERICAL LEAVE WITH
CONFIDENCE MISLI. GOOD MORNING
SAYING BY STRUCK FONG MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- COOLEY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS
THE CHAIR STATED- HERE TO
PRESENT ON THREE BILLS THE
FIRST IS SB NINETY FIVE WHICH
PROVIDES KOBE NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE-
TO EMPLOYEES TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF. THE VIRUS IN THE
WORKPLACE AND THE OTHER TWO
BILLS EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE AND
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT INCLUDE
CLEAN UP AMENDMENTS TO BILLS
THAT WERE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED INTO LAW
BY THE GOVERNOR- AS PART OF AN
IMMEDIATE. BUDGET ACTION
PACKAGE THAT PROVIDES FINANCIAL
SUPPORTS TO- LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED. BY
COULD NINETEEN- I AM HAPPY TO-
PRESENT ALL THREE BACK TO BACK-
CHEER TEAM OR I CAN TAKE ONE AT
A TIME WHAT WHICHEVER IS YOUR
PLEASURE YOU'RE JUST COOL
WATCHES GO ALL THREE TOGETHER.
OKAY GREAT. OKAY STARTING WITH
SB FIVE- THIS BILL REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE UP TO
EIGHTY HOURS OF KOBE NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL KATE SICK LEAVE TO
ALLEMPLOYEES THROUGH
SEPTEMBER. OF THIS YEAR
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF THIS
YEAR. HOWEVER IT DOES EXEMPTS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AS WELL
AS EMPLOYERS WITH TWENTY FIVE
OR FEWER EMPLOYEES- HOWEVER
BUSINESSES THAT. EMPLOY
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS OR THE
SMALLER BUSINESSES HAVE THE
OPTION TO PROVIDE PAID SICK
LEAVE UNDER THE FEDERAL
PROVISIONS- AND THEY WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR. THE RECEIPT OF A
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT. THE BILL
ALSO PROVIDES THAT ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYEES MAY USE THEIR KOBE
NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL HEAT SICK
LEAVE. UP TO QUARANTINE OR
ISOLATE AND- IN ORDER BY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO SEEK A
MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS IT
EXPERIENCING PUBLIC NINETEEN
SYMPTOMS. FOR AN APPOINTMENT
BURKE WILL BE NINETEEN BACK IN-
IF THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
SYMPTOMS AS A RESULT OF THAT
VACCINE. TO CARE FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER WHO HAS BEEN ADVISED TO
QUARANTINE AND TO CARE FOR A
CHILD WHOSE SCHOOL OR PLACE OF
CHILD CARE HAS CLOSED DUE TO
CALL THE NINETEEN ON THE
PROMISES. THE BILL ALSO PER CO
BE NINETEEN. CATHOLIC LEAVE FOR
A HOMES AND SERVICES AND WEAVER
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES
PROVIDERS. THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL ARE RETROACTIVE TO
SICK LEAVE TAKEN BEGINNING
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR AND
I THINK AS I STATED EARLIER
THIS BILL SUNSET. ON SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MOVING ON TO AB EIGHTY THREE-
WHICH IS THE LICENSE RENEWAL
FEE WAIVER- AB EIGHTY THREE
AMENDS SB NINETY FOUR WHICH WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW AND PROVIDE
ECONOMIC RELIEF TO LICENSEES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL- THIS IS
PRIMARILY BARS AND RESTAURANTS.
AT THAT WERE HARD HIT BY THE
OPERATIONAL IMPACTS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY ORDERS ISSUED
TO MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF KOBE
NINETEEN. EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE
ADDS THREE ADDITIONAL LICENSE
TYPES THESE ARE SMALL WIPERS.
THAT'S AND CRACKED DOLLARS TO
THOSE SEVEN TYPES OF OFFER FOR
TO SB NINETY- THREE SEE WHERE
FOR A- LIFE. FEES THE BILL
PROVIDES THREE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND TO BACK FILL LOST
SPECIAL BY REVENUE THAT LICENSE
FEES OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE PAID
TO THE DEPARTMENT. WE ESTIMATE
THE WAIVERS WILL PROVIDE
ECONOMIC RELIEF TO
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FOUR
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL LICENSEES.
AND THEN MOVING ON TO THE LAST
BILL AB EIGHTY EIGHT HOUR
CRITICAL STATE TO ME LET'S
PROGRAM. AB EIGHT EIGHT A MAN
SB EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW AND PROVIDES A
ONE TIME STIMULUS PAYMENT OF
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. THE
QUALIFYING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT ALSO
KNOWN AS CAL EITC- AND FOR I.
TEN HOUSEHOLDS THAT NEED LESS
THAN SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND IN
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME FOR TAX
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY. SB EIGHTY
EIGHT ALSO PROVIDES A ONE TIME
SIX HUNDRED SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
PAYMENT TO HOUSEHOLDS ENROLLED
IN THE KALMYKS PROGRAM.
RECIPIENTS OF FSIS IS KEY AND
KATHY ORR KATHY. SPECIFICALLY
EIGHTY EIGHT CLEAR. THAT
CRAPPIE ARE. FROM TAX. STATE
TAXES AND EXEMPTS THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS- AS WELL AS THE
GRANT PROGRAM PAYMENTS FROM
GARNISHMENT ORDERS EXCEPT FOR
CHILD SUPPORT SPOUSAL SUPPORT
FAMILY SUPPORT OR CRIMINAL
RESTITUTION PAYABLE TO PICKED
UP. AND LASTLY IT CLARIFIES THE
DEFINITION OF GRANT RECIPIENT
AND INCLUDE SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TIED TO AUTOMATION.
THOSE ARE ON THE THREE BILLS
THAT WILL BE PRESENTED ON TODAY
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS I'M- TRYING BY MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU. THIS JUDY
OF ANY COMMENTS HELLO. A GOOD
MORNING CAROLINE SHE FROM THE
L. A. OTIS HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- THAT YOU ALL MAY
HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU LET'S GO
TO. MY COLLEAGUES THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE- WITH. FOR I'M IF I
CAN ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON- ON AB EIGHTY FOUR
SB NINETY FIVE CERTAINLY- THERE
IS THE- CLAIM THAT ANY FEDERAL
TAX CREDITS- WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO BE USED TO OFFSET THE COST
HERE BUT THE ONE I LIKE TO GET
YOUR RESPONSE IN TERMS OF- A
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO MAY ACCESS
THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS TO
OFFSET SOME OF THESE BECAUSE
THEY WON'T HAVE THE IMMEDIATE
CAPITAL. TWO US BAND IN THE
PAYROLL COSTS- WITH THIS
MANDATE AND THE FACT THAT IT'S
ALSO RETROACTIVE ALSO CREATES
ANOTHER IMAGE- ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN. COULD YOU ELABORATE ON
TERMS OF HAL- HOW HOW WE SHOULD
RECONCILE THAT. SURE MISTER
BOND LET ME FIRST SAY THAT THIS
IS NOT- ANYTHING NEW BUT THIS
IS A CONTINUATION OF- OF WHAT
WAS PROVIDED IN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER- MENTIONED EARLIER AS
WELL AS IN- EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN AND SO THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE
EXPECTATIONS AND BUSINESSES-
ALONG WITH- JUST AGAIN POINT
OUT THE FEDERAL CREDIT WHICH IS
QUITE GENEROUS IT PROVIDES A-
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR COMPENSATION.
IN TERMS OF A TAX CREDIT- AND-
UNDERSTAND A QUESTION IS THE UP
FRONT COST AND I THINK THAT
THAT NEEDS TO BE BALANCED WITH
THE INTENT OF THE BILL WHICH IS
REALLY TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
KOBE IN THE WORKPLACE. AND TO
ENCOURAGE THOSE TO TAKE- TIME
OFF TO RECEIVE VACCINATIONS. SO
IS IT THE POSITION OF THE
MINISTRATION THAT A SMALL
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THIS IS THIS IS AN IT IN
ADDITION TO. WITH A FEDERAL-
LEAVE AND ADDED IN ADDITION TO
EVERY OTHER ADDITIONAL LEAVES
THAT WERE FROM THAT WERE
MANDATED. SELL YOU SAYING THAT
A SMALL BUSINESS CAN CAN CLAIM
THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT FOR ALL
THESE LEAVES NOW. I'M YEAH LET
ME LET ME CLARIFY AND ALSO
STATE THERE IS AN EXEMPTION IN
THIS BILL OF FOR EMPLOYERS WHO
HAVE TWENTY FIVE OR LESS
EMPLOYEES AND JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE FACT THAT-
THERE IS WELL THERE'S A
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THIS IS A
BIRD AND A FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
SOME SMALL BUSINESSES SO I JUST
WANT TO POINT THAT OUT AND I
APOLOGIZE I DID NOT THINK THAT
OUT OF MY EARLIER RESPONSE- BUT
THAT IS RECOGNITION- OF SMALL
BUSINESS IMPACT SMALL BUSINESS-
AND IN REGARDS TO THE FEDERAL
CREDIT THE FEDERAL CREDIT IS.
IS PROVIDED PURSUANT TO- BOTH
THE- THE FAMILY FIRST I RUN A
VIRUS ACT AS WELL AS SUBSEQUENT
FINANCIAL FIT FEDERAL STIMULUS-
ACTS THAT PROVIDE CREDIT SO
WHATEVER- BELIEVE IS PROVIDED
PURSUANT TO THOSE BILLS- ARE
THOSE ACTS WOULD RECEIVE THE
FEDERAL CREDIT AND THIS THE
CURRENT CREDIT- IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE EXTENSION OF THE
FIGURE OUT OF THE FAMILY FIRST
AFTER THAT WAS PROVIDED- BY THE.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON LAST YEAR.
SO I GUESS MAYBE AT MOMENT LET
ME A THIS AND I GUESS AND A
DIFFERENT WAY MAYBE THAT WILL
CLARIFY FOR ME. CAN A SMALL
BUSINESS OR KIND OF BUSINESS
THAT SAY THAT'S NOT EXEMPTED.
CANVEY OFFSET. THE COST DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR. OF THIS NEW MANDATE
WITH THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT.
WELL WILL THERE BE ADDITIONAL
COSTS TO AN EMPLOYER THAT HAS
TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES. CHARS SO
FOR EVERY EMPLOYER WHO PROVIDES
A SICK LEAVE- ABOVE AGAINST
ABOUT THAT TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX EMPLOYEES THEY WILL RECEIVE
A FEDERAL CREDIT- THAT A DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR WORTH THE
COMPENSATION THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO THE EMPLOYEE. BUT AS A COVER
THAT I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
DOES IT COVERED THIS ADDITIONAL
MANDATE. YES SERVICE YES IT
DOES OKAY FEDERAL CREDIT WOULD
BE PROVIDED PURSUANT TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
ALIGNED TO THE FEDERAL. OKAY
AND THEN CAN CAN YOU JUST- I
GUESS ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF PAGA
AND WIDE THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL. WITH THE NECESSARY.
THEY HAVE A TO ADD LOCATION TO
THIS. BILL SURE AND LET ME TURN
THAT QUESTION OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE DANIEL BRANDON WHO
MAY HAVE SOME MORE DETAILS ON
PAGA. EIGHT YES DANIEL BRANDON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE DON'T THAT THE LABOR
CODE SECTION WOULD ALLOW IN
PLACE FLEXIBLE PENALTIES. AND
HOWEVER. VIGIL WOULD NEED TO
ASK FOR THAT LEAD BEFORE ANY OF
THE PENALTIES- APPLIED WE THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF THE
WORKERS TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO TAKE THIS TIME OFF. I
THINK I'D A MESSAGE I THINK MY
AND MY CONCERN IS QUITE
INTELLIGENCE LOCALS CONTINUES
TO HOLD THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
CALL. IS THAT- THAT WE KNOW OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OUR
COMMUNITY ARE STRUGGLING AND
THIS IS AN ADDITIONAL MANDATE I
DON'T BELIEVE- WILL BE COPIED
THE WILL BE OVER OFFSET BY THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS BECAUSE OF
THE TIMING OF EVERYTHING AND
THE UP FRONT COSTS AND
LITIGATION ADDED TO AT THIS
TIME IS- I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE JUST ADD MORE
COSTLY LITIGATION. ON TO SMALL
BUSINESSES TRYING TO SURVIVE.
FIGURE MUCHAS CHAIR. THANK YOU.
COOPER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IS THE FOLLOW UP ON- MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTION SO WHAT
ABOUT FOR EMPLOYER DID PROVIDE
LEAVING JANUARY COULD BE
EMPLOYER BE SUBJECT TO A
LAWSUIT ON THE PART OF OUR
CIVIL FOR CIVIL PENALTIES. LET
ME JUST. MAKE ONE POINT AND I
THINK I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AS WELL- SO IF AN
EMPLOYER PROVIDED PAID SICK OR
SICK LEAVE. TO AN EMPLOYEE IN
JANUARY OR BEYOND JANUARY UP
UNTIL THEY'VE ACTIVATED THE
SPELL IT WOULD GET CREDIT
BASICALLY FOR THOSE HOURS. AND
RECEIVED A CREDIT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THOSE
THOSE HOURS WOULD COUNT TOWARDS
THAT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL- I'M NOT SURE THAT
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION BUT I JUST WANT TO-
UNDER SCHIANO UNDERSCORE THE
FACT THAT THIS IS. A BILL
THAT'S RETROACTIVE TO JANUARY
ONE OF THIS YEAR. OKAY THANK
YOU- WELL I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT TO ENSURE THERE
IS A GAP BETWEEN THE
EXPIRATION. OF AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THE
REINSTATEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
PAID SICK LEAVE FOR ONE JERRY
FIRST. I CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RETROACTIVE CHANGE THE WALL SO.
MANY THE SMALL BUSINESSES IN MY
DISTRICT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
POTETIAL EMPLOYER LIABILITY.
THIS ISSUE BEEN ADDRESSED IN
THE BILL SO THAT THE BUSINESSES
ARE NOT HELD RETRACT WITH
VIABLE FOR PENALTIES FOR
EXAMPLE. THEY DID NOT COMPETENT
EMPLOYEE FOR PAID SICK LEAVE.
DURING THE PAST TWO ONE HALF
MONTHS. WHEN EMPLOYERS NOT HAVE
A LEGAL OBLIGATION TO DO SO.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER DANIEL
BRANDON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BELIEVE PROVIDED AND-
IF. SO IF THE LEAVE PROVIDED BY
THE EMPLOYER BETWEEN JACK. TIME
THE BILL IS SIGNED IS THAT IS
ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS PROGRAM
THEN THE EMPLOYER WOULD GET
CREDIT THE EMPLOYER WOULD ALSO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
RIGHT OR TO MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR K. IF THEY
HADN'T DONE SO. WHAT I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT AN EMPLOYER I'M
SORRY IN AN EMPLOYEE WOULD HAVE
TO MAKE THAT REQUEST. AFTER
THIS LEGISLATION IS SIGNED AND
THEN AN EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE TO
NOT COMPLY AT THAT TIME BEFORE-
CIVIL ACTION COULD BE TAKEN
THANK YOU. UP BUT IF IT DOES
BECOME AN ISSUE WITH THE AUTHOR
COMMIT TO ADDRESSING THIS THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES TO EMPLOYERS
AREN'T HARM FOR THIS
RETROACTIVELY. RETROACTIVITY IN
THIS IMPORTANT IN IN MY BOOK.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- I I'LL HAVE TO GO
BACK TO- HAVE A DISCUSSION IN
TERMS OF HOW THE INTERACTION IS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES BUT I HEAR I
HEAR THE CONCERN- MISTER COOPER
OKAY JUST IN A REALLY BIG ISSUE
IS THAT A LOT OF US HAVE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR DISTRICT.
INTERSPINOUS BEEN BEEN TOUGH ON
THEM AND- YOU KNOW A LOT OF
CLOSED IN THE ONE THE
REMAINING- REALLY TEETERING ON
THE BRINK OF SHUTTING DOWN SO-
I THINK WE'VE GOT TO JUST BE
VERY BALANCED IN OUR APPROACH
TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP THE
EMPLOY. A LARGE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS OF THANK YOU. YES
I MAY I JUST ADD THAT- IN
ISOLATION I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF SOME
OF THE MEMBERS. BUT I ALSO LIKE
TO POINT OUT THE MANY- OF
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED
INTO LAW BY THE GOVERNOR. THAT
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS SUPPORTS INCLUDING
FRANCE- ACCREDITS- THAT RELIEF
IN OTHER FORMS. AND AGAIN THERE
IS THAT EXEMPTION FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THIS BILL. WHICH
I UNDERSTAND- ENCOMPASSES OVER
90% OF THE BUSINESSES AND
CALIFORNIA SO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT IN TOTALITY.
THERE IS A PACKAGE OF-
PROPOSALS THAT IS REALLY
LOOKING AT. A TOTAL TOTAL NOT A
TAX RELIEF AND- SUPPORT FOR
SMALL BUSINESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER- QUESTIONS. COMMENTS
THIS PRESS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I THINK THAT THE WHAT I
LIKE ABOUT THE BILL IS THAT IT
DOES TRY TO FIND SOME BALANCE
WE HAVE TO BE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE DO NOT DENY SICK LEAVE TO
THOSE WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
PUBLIC AND PUTTING THEIR THEIR
LIFE IN DANGER FOR US WE ALSO
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I'M THAT
SICK EMPLOYEES DON'T GO TO WORK
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO RECEIVE ANY BENEFITS.
OUGHT NOT SPECIFICALLY ON CARGO
PLANES IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE WAS NO OUTPOURING OF
PAGA LITIGATION OR FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN OR THE FOOD WORKER
EXECUTIVE ORDER- THE BILL
BEFORE US SIMPLY EXTENDS
EXISTING PRACTICE SO THE
QUESTION THEN IS CAN CAN WOULD
YOU CONFIRM THAT NO NEW PAGA
RIGHTS OR OTHER PRIVATE RIGHTS
OF ACTION OR AVENUES TOWARD
LARGER WARDS HAVE BEEN CREATED
IN THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY.
YES AGAIN- HIGHLIGHT IN AGREE
WITH- YOU IN REGARDS TO THAT
THIS IS NOT ANYTHING NEW THIS
IS A CONTINUATION OF-
PROVISIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED
IN AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. AND
IT- THE- ALSO AGREED THAT THERE
WAS NOT A SPIKE IN APOCALYPSE
RELATED LITIGATION BUT I WILL
TURN THE QUESTION VER FOR
FURTHER DETAILS TO MY COLLEAGUE
DANIEL BRANDON. THANK YOU
MEMBER FOR THE QUESTION
DANIELLE BRANDON AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M LIKE
MISLI HAD STATED AND WE'RE NOT
AWARE OF- OF LARGE ON SET OF
CLAIMS AS REGARDED THIS AND
THEN PAGI GUEST. REALLY APPLIES
IN CERTAIN AGREE JUST CASES AND
EMPLOYERS ARE ALLOWED TO CURE
THOSE VIOLATIONS BEFORE THE
PENALTIES APPLY- WITH REGARD TO
YOUR SPECIFIC SOME TALK THAT I
MAY NEED TO DEFER TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING MORE SPECIFIC. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU AND I ALSO
WOULD ASK- IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ELABORATE ON THE PAGA CLAIMS
GOING FORWARD. DO THEY PENALIZE
EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE MADE
INSIGNIFICANT. OR GOOD FAITH
ERRORS. THANK YOU DANIEL. GOD
ANNA SORRY. MY APOLOGIES AND-
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW AN
EMPLOYEE TO REQUEST- TO BE MADE
WHOLE UNDER THIS SPELL AT WHICH
TIME THE EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY BEFORE A CLAIM
COULD BE FILED. THANK YOU AYE I
THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- IN FINDING THAT
BALANCE. THAT WE PROTECT OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE THAT
WOULD HAVE DONE SO MUCH DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING OUR
OUR EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE BEEN THE
BACKBONE OF ALL THOSE JOBS
THANK YOU. MYSTERONS. THANK YOU
I'M THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
ON THE ISSUE OF- BUSINESSES WE
KNOW THAT THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN HIT PRETTY
HARD ESPECIALLY IN- MY DISTRICT
THE ASSEMBLY FORTY TH DISTRICT
OF NOT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT THAT
BUSINESSES IN GENERAL HAVE-
SUFFERED- WE KNOW THAT SOME
BUSINESSES HAVE GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS DURING THIS- COVERT
NINETEEN ERA. AND ORIGINALLY IN
THIS BILL LAST YEAR WE HAVE
PROTECTION FOR EMPLOYEES WITH
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR LESS-
AND NOW WE HAVE IN THEIR TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS SO MY
FIRST QUESTION IS GOING TO THE
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES DOES THAT REPRESENT
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YES THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
I BELIEVE THAT. AND I WILL TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE DANIEL RENDON
FOR THE EXACT MEASURE BUT AGAIN
THIS THIS BILL- WOULD REQUIRE
ALL BUSINESSES. EXCEPT THOSE
TWENTY WITH EMPLOYEES OF TWENTY
FIVE OR LESS TO- PROVIDE THIS
SICK LEAVE AND- DANIELLE RENDON
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAILS IN REGARDS TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE WHOLE THAT
MAKES. IS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- I MAY HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF- THAT COVERS I
BELIEVE IT IS ROUGHLY ABOUT 90%
I AM. WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT
FOLLOW UP AND- WHAT WAS THAT
NUMBER MISTER. I WOULD LIKE AN
APOLOGY IS THE MEMBER I WOULD
LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON. GEN- AND
CONFIRM I NEVER SO WE'RE NOT
CLEAR ON WHAT PERCENT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT THAT 25% OF
EMPLOYEES ACTUALLY AFFECTS. YES
AT THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE THAT
FIGURE- WE CAN PROVIDE THAT TO
YOU- THIS OF THIS COMMITTEE
AFTER THE HEARING. THANK YOU-
JUST BRING IT UP MISTER CHAIR
AS FAR AS A BUSINESSES AND
SECTORS THAT HAVE SORT OF BEEN
HIT AND A LOT OF BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS-
BUT ALSO I WANT- YOU KNOW-
CONFIRMATION THAT THIS- ACTUAL-
BILL. THE WRITER BILL HERE
TRAILER BILL WILL EXPIRE IN
SEPTEMBER OF. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. YES THAT IS PRACTICE BUILT
ON SITE AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER
OF THIS YEAR. THANK YOU- AND WE
CANNOT GET MAYBE AN EMAIL OR
SOMETHING IN IN REAL TIME TO
GIVE US THAT NUMBER OF THE-
PERCENTAGES OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR
LESS. ACTUALLY WILL COVER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DEEPLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU MR JEFF.
I THINK THE OTHER THING TO ADD
WOULD JUST ALSO BE- TO PROVIDE
CONTEXT AS THE- NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES WILL LOOK AT THE
OTHER WITH THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES THAT THE BILL WILL
COVER TO. BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A- VERY LARGE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES IN THE IN THE OTHER
POCKET SELF. YES WE'LL GET THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ON UP NUMBER FOUR ON THE
PROVISIONS OF THE SUMMARY
SPECIFICALLY SAYS FIREFIGHTERS
WOULDN'T COVER THE OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
BECAUSE I'M JUST THINKING OF
YOUR DETECTIVE YOU DON'T JUST
STOP AT FORTY HOURS ON A CASE
YOU KEEP GOING UNTIL YOU. REACH
A CONCLUSION TO THE CASE. BUT
WHY DOES IT SAY JUST
FIREFIGHTERS BUT NOT ALL PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL. I HAD A
QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE DANIEL
RENDON THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBER FACT QUESTION
DANIEL BRANDON I AM GOING TO
HAVE TO AND GET BACK TO YOU
WITH THAT QUESTION AS WELL AND
WITH SPECIFICALLY WITH SAFETY-
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS THAT
ALL EMPLOYEES ARE COVERED IF
THEY WORK FOR AN EMPLOYER WITH
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES- AND SO I WILL FOLLOW
UP SPECIFIC. OKAY. OTHER MISS
RUBIO. THOSE ARE JUST MAKING A
FOLLOW UP YES INCOME FROM MY
FELLOW COLLEAGUES OF **** AND
CO WE NEED AN ANSWER BECAUSE
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE VOTING ON
THIS THIS AFTERNOON SO IF YOU
COULD GET A ANSWER FOR VERBALLY
BEFORE NOON TODAY SO WE CAN
RESEARCH HAS. TO BE VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THIS RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
TERRY THE IT'S THE EXACT SAME
COMMENTER FOR EXPECTED TO VOTE
ON THIS ITEM AT TWO AFTER TWO
PM TODAY THAT INFORMATION
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE FOR
US THIS MORNING SOLD- I
UNDERSTAND BAD THAT WERE BEING
OFFERED THE INFORMATION AFTER
THIS MEETING BY- SOMEBODY
SHOULD HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE HOPEFULLY BY THE TIME
THE MEETING AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISFIRES THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN SO AS SOMEBODY WHO
COMES FROM A SMALL BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE IN A WORLD I'M
REALLY CONCERNED THAT WHEN ARE
SMALL SMALL BUSINESSES AND
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAVE REALLY STEPPED UP TO THE
PLATE OVER THE LAST YEAR. I'VE
HEARD STORIES FROM EMPLOYERS
AND COMPANIES IN MY DISTRICT TO
HAVE KEPT EMPLOYEES ON JUST SO
THAT THEY WOULD EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAD NO WORK JUST SO THEY
COULD CONTINUE THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE. SO I'M REALLY
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING
A BALANCED APPROACH APPROACH
WITH THIS. I DO WANT TO KNOW
THE WHAT HOW AND WHY WAS A
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEE THRESHOLD
DEEMED. THE CUT OFF. HIGHER
COOLEY WITH A PERMANENT
FINANCE- AGAIN IN RECOGNITION
OF- THE FISCAL IMPACT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES OR LESS- WAS A POINT
THAT SEEM TO COINCIDE WITH SOME
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION- PROPOSALS AT
THE FEDERAL LAW OKAY- AND
ENCOMPASSED- MANY OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AGAIN WE'LL GET YOU
THAT NUMBER BUT WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS JUST
CONCERNING THAT WE PICKED THIS
NUMBER YET WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
HOW IT IMPACTS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF BUSINESSES. THANK
YOU MISS MCCARTY. YEAH I KNOW
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WE'RE NOT VOTING AGES
FLESHING OUT THE DETAILS AND I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT TWO
THINGS WHICH I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT- FIRST IS WORK IN THE
MIDDLE OF PANDEMIC AND
HOPEFULLY WILL BE OVER IN THE
COMING MONTHS AND VACCINES ARE
ROLLING OUT AND THINGS ARE
CERTAINLY CHANGING AND WE DO
HAVE AN END DATE FOR THIS
POLICY AS MISTER. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAMBAR DINO ASKS
WHO WAS IT WAS REITERATED THAT
WE DO HAVE AN END DATE FOR
THIS. AND THEN I THINK TO NOTE.
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE EMPLOYED BY
SMALL BUSINESS AND KEEP IN THE
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE FROM
SMALLER BUSINESSES OF. LESS
THAN FIFTEEN LESS THAN TEN LESS
THAN FIVE. LAST YEAR WE HAD THE
BIG CONTROVERSIAL DEBATE ON
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. I BELIEVE
THE FINAL- NUMBER WAS MUCH MUCH
LOWER. SO BY THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GOING UP TO TWENTY FIVE I
THINK. HAS SOME RECOGNITION
THAT THE SMALLER BUSINESSES
WITH. THE MAJORITY OF ISN'T
CALIFORNIA HAVE JUST A FEW
EMPLOYEES AND THEY DON'T HAVE.
PERSONNEL TO TEAMS IN PAYROLL-
TEAMS AND CONSULTANTS ALL
FIGURED OUT. SO I THINK BY THE
FACT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
TWENTY FIVE. IT'S A FAIR
COMPROMISE HIS TO FALL BECAUSE
ONE THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE GOING TO GET
SICK YOU CAN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS BECAUSE THEY WORK. FOR
AN EMPLOYER WITH UNDER TWENTY
FIVE IN THE MAJORITY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. FRANKLY WON'T BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
THEY WORK FOR. AN EMPLOYER.
THAT HAS FEWER THAN TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES SO- I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW MANY WOULD PUSH THE OTHER
WAY THAT WE SHOULD GO DOWN TO
FIVE OR LESS. OR EVEN FEWER SO
I JUST THINK WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE- RECONCILE THOSE TWO
FACTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF
MISTER BENNETT THE MISCREANTS.
I DON'T QUESTION THEIR AGO BOB.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE IMPORTANT THING HERE
IS THAT WE'RE MAKING A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO TRY TO PROTECT
WORKERS AND STILL COME UP WITH
SOME KIND OF BALANCE SAYS- MY
COLLEAGUE- MENTIONED IN WHEN
YOU HAVE PROTECTIONS BUILT IN
FOR EXAMPLE. THE EMPLOYER CAN
MAKE THE EMPLOYEE HOLE. ONE
NOTIFIED OF AN ERROR MESSAGE-
THAT I THINK REALLY INDICATES
WE ARE MAKING A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT. IT'S ONLY THE BAD
ACTORS THAT YOU REALLY TRYING
TO FORCES LEGISLATION DOWN AND
MOST WORK SITUATIONS ONCE THIS
LEGISLATION IS AFTER AND IT'S
ONLY FOR EMPLOYERS OF TWENTY
FIVE OR MORE- I THINK YOU YOU
CAN CERTAINLY CALDERON-
EVERYBODY THAT'S TRYING TO MAKE
A GOOD FAITH EFFORT. WILL NOT
GET TRIPPED UP WITH SOME
TECHNICALITIES HERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISS KOREA
THE MISSED MEDINA. THANKS TEST
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS. I THINK ALL
OF US. IN THE PAST YEAR AS WE
REACH THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF OUR GOING INTO QUARANTINE
AND- REALLY THAT THE IMPACT OF
COPA NINETEEN WE HAVE ALL.
KNOWN SOMEONE ESPECIALLY HERE
IN THIS BODY IN THIS BUILDING
THAT HAS BEEN COLD BUT POSITIVE
WE HAVE ALL BEEN IMPACTED BY
SOMEONE WHO HAS. UNFORTUNATELY
PASSED AWAY BECAUSE OF CULVERT.
I HAVE NOT BEEN VOCAL ABOUT
THIS PUBLICLY BUT I HAVE ALSO
LOST FAMILY BECAUSE OF COVERT
NINETEEN AND IT IS. INCREDIBLY
PAINFUL IT IS PAINFUL TO THINK
ABOUT ESSENTIAL AND FRONTLINE
WORKERS WHO ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES EVERY DAY WHO HAVE RISKED
THEIR LIVES. EVERY DAY SO THAT
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
COULD STAY HOME AND QUARANTINE
AND ISOLATE AND GET THEIR
GROCERIES DELIVERED THEY'RE
STILL A HUMAN BEING BEHIND THAT
DELIVERY. THERE'S A HUMAN BEING
BEHIND. SOMEONE WHO WAS
STOCKING THE GROCERY STORE
THERE IS A HUMAN BEING AT YOUR
FAVORITE THAI RESTAURANT THAT
YOU GET DELIVERED THROUGH YOUR
FAVORITE APPS THAT CONTINUES TO
BE EXPOSED EVERY SINGLE DAY. WE
ARE DOING THE VERYBEST WE CAN
TO HAVE BOTH PROTECTIONS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH WE
WORKED REALLY HARD ON. END AND
ALSO DO THE WORK NECESSARY THAT
WE NEED TO DO TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IS
NOT A CONVERSATION ABOUT EITHER
AND I HAVE BEEN. I HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED AND AMUSED AT THE
SAME TIME. THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE SINGULAR IT'S
EITHER BUSINESS OR IT'S EITHER
WORKERS AND I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU TODAY AND I WILL MOVE THIS
FORWARD EVERY DAY THAT I
CONTINUE TO SERVE IN THIS
ASSEMBLY. THAT IT'S BOTH WE CAN
DO BOTH WE CAN PROTECT OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH ARE THE
BACKBONE. OF THE CALIFORNIA AND
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY ECONOMY
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT THAT
I LOVE. AND THAT I DON'T WANT
TO SEE SHUT DOWN. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME WE CAN PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
WORKERS THAT MAKE OUR ECONOMY
RUN WE CAN DO BOTH AND WE
SHOULD. DO BOTH. I WENT TO
REALLY QUICKLY ON TO THE S. P.
A. DOT GOV WEBSITE AND I WAS
ABLE TO LOOK UP NUMBERS FOR. A
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES AND
IN FACT IS VERY IS LAID OUT
VERY. VERY SIMPLY WANT TO
TWENTY EMPLOYERS IN A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT- TYPES OF
INDUSTRIES- TOTALING UP TO SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE. THIS INFORMATION IS
READILY AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF
US. I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR OUR BUDGET
STAFF SINCE IT OUT TO THE YOU
CAN MAKE A CONCISE DECISION
INFILL TRUST AND DECISION THAT
YOU'RE MAKING. ULTIMATELY KNOW
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN
WE DID- AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. IT ONLY COVERED FIVE
HUNDRED PLUS A SIMPLE-
EMPLOYERS BECAUSE FEDERAL LAW
COVERED LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED.
WE WERE WE WERE TRYING TO FIND
THE SAFETY NET. FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ARE WORKING
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
GET PROTECTED. THE BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED FOR
TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER I AM NOT
HAPPY WITH THAT NUMBER. SEVERAL
PEOPLE AREN'T HAPPY WITH THAT
NUMBER SOME PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WANTED LESS FIRE UNLESS
EXCEPTIONS. AND THAT'S OKAY WE
CAME UP WITH TWENTY FIVE THE
SMALL BUSINESS. ADMINISTRATION
TITLES AT ONE TO TWENTY- STAFF.
AND WE CAME TO AN AGREEMENT AND
IT ISN'T PERFECT. BUT IT'S AN
AGREEMENT THAT WE CAME UP WITH%
THAT THIS BODY FEELS GOOD WITH
THE SENATE BILLS GOOD WITH. AND
HOPEFULLY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IS ALSO. IN A GOOD PLACE WITH.
AN AYE SURE THAT TO SAY THAT.
TWENTY FIVE AND UP COVERS TEN
POINT FOUR MILLION WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT IT
IS THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND I
HOPE THAT EVERYONE THAT'S
TALKING ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES
CAN COME TO THE TABLE AND WORK
WITH ME SO THAT WE ENSURE THAT
THOSE THAT ARE TWENTY FIVE AND
UNDER ALSO HAVE PROTECTIONS.
YOUR FAVORITE COFFEE SHOP
AROUND THE CORNER IF ONE
EMPLOYEE GETS. COVERED IN ITS
COVERT POSITIVE AND THEN AND
FAX THE OTHER WORKERS AND THEN
POTENTIALLY HARMS THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING IN TO GET THAT
FAVORITE COFFEE GUESS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. YOUR COFFEE
SHOP IS GOING TO BE A HOT ZONE
AND YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN. NONE OF US WANT
THAT. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
PROTECTED. THAT EMPLOYEES ARE
PROTECTED. THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
CARE FOR A SICK FAMILY MEMBER.
WE ARE ROLLING OUT THE VACCINES
AND THERE'S ISSUES WITH VACCINE
EQUITY THAT I'M SEEN IN MY
COMMUNITY EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
ANOTHER COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS NOT
AN EQUITABLE PROCESS WE ARE NOT
DONE. WITH COLD IT. IT'S STILL
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO LIVE
THROUGH. AND THERE IS A SUNSET
DATE. TO BE SPECIFIC AND TO BE
HELPFUL AND IT FALLS IN LINE
WITH THE FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
GUIDELINES. EVERY BUSINESS IS
ENTITLED TO A TAX CREDIT. OUR
CHARGE IF YOU CARE ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND I HOPE THAT YOU
DO. IS HOW DO WE NOW ENSURE
THAT THOSE TWENTY FIVE AND
UNDER HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
TAX CREDITS WHICH ARE
AVAILABLE. THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY MAY NOT
KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING IT THROUGH THIS. SO
I WOULD URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. TO YES ASK YOUR
QUESTIONS. BUT THEN UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ANSWERS ARE THERE. AND
THERE WE ARE WORKING REALLY
HARD TO ENSURE THAT WE GET TO A
GOOD PLACE. AND THAT ULTIMATELY
EVEN THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE EXEMPTED FROM THIS BILL.
HAVE THE SAME PROTECTIONS WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE UNDER
FEDERAL GUIDELINES INTO THE END
OF SEPTEMBER. THAT'S MY CHARGE
AS WELL. BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
DON'T ONLY CARE ABOUT THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE TWENTY FIVE
AND MORE. THE BREAD THE BREAD
AND BUTTER BUSINESSES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY THRIVES THE
IMMIGRANT- YOU KNOW WHAT HOW
CAN RESTAURANT IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. THAT NEED SUPPORT
THAT ONLY HAS TEN EMPLOYEES I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IMMIGRANT OWNED SMALL BUSINESS
RESTAURANT KNOWS. THAT THEY CAN
STILL OFFER THEIR EMPLOYEE
THOSE TWO WEEKS EVEN THOUGH
IT'S NOT IN THIS BILL. AND IT
IS OUR CHARGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION. SO I HOPE THAT ALL
OF YOU THAT ARE SAYING YOU CARE
ABOUT YOUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT YOU ALSO CARE ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THEY GET THE
INFORMATION- IT'S BEEN. A TOUGH
YEAR MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
TO. THEN THE PANDEMIC MRE THAN
HALF A MILLION. MORE THAN FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND OF THOSE LIVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE CAN
DELIBERATE ALL WE WANT. FULLER
STILL GETTING SICK AND PEOPLE
ARE STILL DYING AND THEY ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN MY
COMMUNITY AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT JUST AS WE ARE
PROTECTING SMALL BUSINESSES
WITH ALL THE SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
PASSED ALREADY. WE CAN DO THE
SAME FOR PEOPLE. BECAUSE
WITHOUT PEOPLE. THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES DON'T SURVIVE THEY
NEED EACH OTHER AND WE CAN DO
BOTH. SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
YES DO EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY
CAN TO PROTECT SMALL BUSINESS
AND ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T
CLOSE I WANT THAT. BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE
DIES ALONG THE WAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND FOLLOWING UP
ON MY COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES- OUR COMMUNICATION. ON
ON PAID SICK LEAVE SO IN A
PRACTICAL SENSE HOW ARE THE
CHANGES AND BENEFITS
COMMUNICATED TO EMPLOYEES AND
EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
FOCUSES ON HUMAN RESOURCES. SO
HOW DO WE COMMUNICATE HOW TO
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYEES I
RECEIVED THE INFORMATION. ON
THE CHANGES SURE. AGAIN THIS
IS- THESE ARE NOT THESE ARE NOT
NEW CHANGES THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAM BOTH AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND STATE LEVEL AND SO
THE MEANS OF COMMUNICATION-
SHOULD BE THE SAME AS IN THE
BEGINNING FOR THE PREVIOUS
PROGRAMS AND THAT WOULD BE-
HUMAN RESOURCES IN- BUSINESSES-
AS WELL AS- INFORMATION- FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND LABOR
COMMISSIONER- THERE ARE. IO'S
THAT ARE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AS WELL AND
SO THERE ARE OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH- FORMAL AND INFORMAL IN
WHICH WORKERS AND WE SHOULD BE
GETTING THIS INFORMATION A
PLAYER SHOULD BE SHARING THAT
INFORMATION OUT. AND THEN IS
THERE A ROLE FOR THE STATE AND
FOLLOWING UP WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
BENEFITS AND WHAT WOULD THAT
ROLE BE. IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND- FOLLOW UP. SURE PROBABLY
SPEAKING- THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF- LABOR LAWS AND
THIS WOULD BE- INCLUDED UNDER
THAT- I THINK FOR FURTHER
DETAILS ALTERNATE QUESTION TO
DANIEL BRANDON THANK YOU. YES
DANIEL BRAND WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
DOES HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO AND
DO INVESTIGATIONS- FOR IN
SITUATIONS WHERE A COMPLAINT
ARISES WE JUST ALSO NOTE THAT
TIME THERE RE CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS. UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING AGAINST. OR OTHER-
SUCH VIOLATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ISRAEL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
ACTUALLY STAND UP AND TALK
ABOUT THE PROCESS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT THAT
WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL OF US HAD
ISSUES WITH WITH THE BILL IN
ITS ORIGINAL FORM AND IN THE
LAST TWO WEEKS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH YOUR OFFICE AND
MISS CREEL'S OFFICE TO TRYING
TO GET SOME SOME- HELP FOR SOME
OF THESE BUSINESSES AND SO JUST
FOR THE REST OF OUR COLLEAGUES
WE CAME UP WITH. WITH THE
TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER-
BUSINESS- ASSISTANCE BUT ALSO
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THOSE MISSED THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER
EMPLOYEES CAN ALSO GET HELP
THEY HAVE TAX BREAKS FOR THIS
IT IS NOT A PERFECT BILL AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- WE HAD ASKED
FOR MORE- MORE AMENDMENTS AND
I'M YOU KNOW WE GOT THREE OUT
OF THE FIVE REQUESTS THAT WE
HAVE PUT IN AND WHICH I THINK
IS YOU MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OF CARS YOU KNOW- BUT
NOT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BE
HAPPY AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER- TO THAT END- I THINK
THAT IN A GOOD NEGOTIATION
PROCESS. BOTH SIDES ARE NEVER
HAPPY AND I WANT TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AT THE END WE
ARE HELPING- BUSINESSES BUT
WE'RE ALSO HELPING THOSE
EMPLOYEES THAT DO SERVE OUR
BUSINESS OUR OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AGAIN IT IS NOT A
PERFECT ALIBIED UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND- DURING THE
PANDEMIC NOTHING HAS BEEN ARE
PREDICTABLE AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT THAT
WE HAVE HAD WE STILL WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME FURTHER- OF A
COMPILE CONVERSATION ON THE
RETROACTIVITY THAT'S BEEN A AN
ISSUE FOR US AS WELL. BUT AGAIN
I THINK THAT- WE HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH AND I
APPRECIATE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
INVOLVEMENT AND THE
RESPONSIVENESS THAT WE'VE HAVE
HAD THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
RUBIO AND I THINK YOUR YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE OTHR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO DIDN'T WANT ANY
EXEMPTIONS IN TERMS OF NUMBER
EMPLOYEES SO I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THIS IS.
VERY MUCH A COMPROMISE AND IT'S
A COMPROMISE THAT TRIES. TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ON BUSINESS
IS TWENTY FIVE AND OVER IN ALSO
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WERE TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER. ARE
ARE EXEMPTED AND REALLY ARE ARE
GIVEN. TAX BREAKS AND GIVEN
OPPORTUNITIES AND GIVEN THIS IS
ON TOP OF THE GRANTS THAT WERE
GIVING AS WELL SO. IT'S REALLY
TRYING TO STRIKE A BALANCE AND
BE SENSITIVE TO. I THINK
EVERYONE'S NEEDS AND I THINK
AS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA ALSO
POINTED OUT. THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND THRIVE
AT THE SAME TIME THAT.
EMPLOYEES DON'T HAVE TO MAKE
THIS CHOICE OF IF I'M SICK DO I
DO I GO TO WORK I NEED THAT
PAYCHECK SO AGAIN. WHAT WE TRY
TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT
AND- WELL WE KNOW THAT WILL BE
CONTINUING THIS CONVERSATION
ABSOLUTELY. MISTER CHAIR MAY I
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH SOME
FURTHER DETAILS IN REGARDS TO
THEIR QUESTIONS REGULAR GREAT
GO HEAD OKAY. SHARE BUT- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY A MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE
EXEMPTED AS- IN REGARDS TO THE
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS.
THAT'S ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION- WORKERS IN THE STATE.
OF ABOUT A TOTAL OF. AROUND
NINETEEN MILLION- WORKERS TO
JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE THAT FOR
CONTEXT- BUT I ALSO- APPRECIATE
THE STATEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE IN REGARDS TO THE OVERALL
AGAIN. OVERALL PACKAGE. OF
SUPPORTS AND RELIEF THAT ARE.
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATIONIS
LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING TO SMALL BUSINESS
IN. REGARDS TO THE WAIVERS-
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS- SMALL
SMALL BUSINESS- PAYMENT
DEFERRALS FOR SALES AND USE
TAXES AS WELL AS OTHER CREDITS-
IT AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HOLDING AND I'M STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU MISLI OTHER. MISTER
COOPER. JUST A COMMON MISTER
CHAIR I THINK ABOUT PARTISAN
WOULD GOTTEN ARGUE WITH-
CALLING FROM- LA- BUBBLE HILLS
THAT IT IT'S A BILL IS NOT THE
BEST BILL BUT IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD MIDDLE GROUND AND IN MY
OPINION COULD HAPPEN A LONG
TIME AGO BECAUSE WE LEFT THE
ALL OF US DON'T DO A GOOD JOB
OF COMMUNICATING AND TALKING
ABOUT THIS IN THE BILL'S COMING
IT'S A BIG IMPORTANT BILL
ACTUALLY GET INTO IT. AND ALSO
THE BILL COMES OUT THIS FORM
THERE'S PUSH BACK BUT I THINK
DIALOGUE HAS TO HAPPEN A LOT
EARLIER IN SOME OF THESE BILLS
IN THE SESSION THE OTHER
SCOLDED BUT WE HAVE PLENTY OF
TIME DURING CAUCUS AND OTHER
MEETINGS TO REALLY TALK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES AND WE HAVEN'T
DONE THAT IN IN SHAME ON US
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. A LOT OF
SUPERFLUOUS THINGS THAT REALLY
DON'T. YOU SERVE THE PEOPLE
WELL. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE
BILLS THIS YEAR SO HOPEFULLY.
LESS THIS WILL GAUGE AND MORE
ROBUST DIALOGUE. BEFORE COMES
BEFORE BEFORE WE HAD IF WE CAN.
TRY TO RESOLVE SOME OF THESE
THINGS AND- I KNOW TWENTY FIVE
A GOOD NUMBER BUT- LET'S BE
HONEST THERE. ARE SOME
RESTAURANTS THAT EMPLOY TWENTY
FIVE PEOPLE. FOR OPEN FROM
LUNCHTIME TO DINNER. IT'S VERY
EASY GO THAT TWENTY FIVE PERSON
THING SO. I KNOW FINANCES
QUOTED A NUMBER OF WHATEVER ONE
MILLION BUT STILL. A LOT OF
FAMILY OWNED RESTAURANTS. SMALL
BUSINESSES. DO EMPLOY MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE. IN WORK SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE TOUGH PART
BECAUSE IT REALLY AFFECTS THEM
AND- I HEAR. DAY IN AND DAY OUT
OF. MY DISTRICT IS VERY
DIVERSE. A LOT OF RESTAURANTS
BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS SO.
TWENTY FIVE GOOD. BUT IS STILL
IN PATH ONE FOLKS THAT ARE
GOING TO HAVE TROUBLE. THANK
YOU MR. THANK THANK YOU MISTER
FROM THE STRESS. TO OF FOLLOW
UP AND JUST AS THE- OF CLARA. I
DO WANT TO CONFIRM THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. SIGNED BY
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN. WILL
REIMBURSE COVERED EMPLOYERS FOR
THE COST OF PROVIDING THE SICK
LEAVE IS THAT CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT- AND IT IS THIS UNDER
THE SAME COMPENSATION TERMS
THAT WAS PROVIDED UNDER THE
ORIGINAL- FAMILY FIRST ACT.
WHICH IS FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN
DOLLARS PER DAY WITH A CAP OF
OVER JUST OVER FIVE THOUSAND SO
YES THE CREDIT WILL BE A DOLLAR
DOLLAR DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
COMPENSATION- CREDIT TO THE
EMPLOYER. THANK YOU. OKAY
MISTER COOPER THE MYSTERY SURE
MR IS MORPHING TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT THE PRIOR BILL AND IT
JUST ANOTHER PART BILL IS NOT
RETROACTIVE IN FACT HAD A TEN
DAY FACING IS THAT CORRECT.
FROM FINANCE. I BELIEVE THAT IS
CORRECT SO I'M TO OPEN I HEARD
SOME PEOPLE TALK ABOUT EARLIER
YOU COMPARING APPLES AND
ORANGES SO LIKE I SAID IT WAS A
TEN DAY PHASE IN. AND NOT
RETROACTIVE SO TO ME IN MY MIND
THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISCREANT. I
JUST WANTED TO ADD TO I BELIEVE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST SAID- REGARDING BEAT
MICHAEL MY COLLEAGUES QUESTION-
FOR EXAMINERS ARE ADDING. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN IT ALSO
INCLUDES WILL WE HAVE. EXCLUDED
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
INCLUDES ALL BUSINESSES
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT ARE
TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER WHICH WE
ARE NOT. COVERING UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL. SO AGAIN FOR EVERYONE
THAT'S CONCERNED ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
THE TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER.
WHICH INCLUDE SMALL RESTAURANTS
THAT ARE NOT OPERATING AT FULL
CAPACITY. THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
TWENTY FIVE AND UP THAT THEY
WOULD TRADITIONALLY HAVE.
BECAUSE OF CODE. BECAUSE OF
CLOSURES BECAUSE OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN THE LAST YEAR. SO I HOPE
THAT THERE IS AN EFFORT IN THIS
BODY. TO ALSO HELP THE TWENTY
FIVE AND UNDER EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE EXCLUDING THEM. KNOWING
THAT THERE IS A FAT THERE IS
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR TAX
CREDITS. SO THAT THOSE
EMPLOYEES CAN ALSO. BE
PROTECTED UNDER COVERT PAID
SICK LEAVE. IT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE STATE RIGHT NOW
BUT IT IS AVAILABLE. AND I
HOPE. THAT WE ALL DO THE WORK
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
THAT ARE STILL. TWENTY FIVE AND
UNDER NO. THAT THEY CAN STILL
APPLY FOR THOSE TAX CREDITS
THEY CAN STILL OPERATE AND THEY
CAN STILL SUPPORT THEIR
EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MAY I ADD TO THAT
STATEMENT YES. YEAH OKAY AT YES
AND I JUST WANT TO ALSO SAY
THAT THE FEDERAL LAW IS ONLY
FORTY EMPLOYERS A FIVE HUNDRED
OR LESS AND THIS- SB NINETY
FIVE NINETY. FIVE WHERE-
APPLIES TO ALL EMPLOYERS- OVER
TWENTY FIVE AND I'M TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS POINTS. THOSE
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESSES MAY
STILL OFFER THE PAID SICK LEAVE
AND RECEIVE THE FEDERAL CREDIT
THEIR DOES NOT MANDATED TO DO
SO. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER THIS
IS MISTER RAMOS RIGHT OKAY YOUR
VIEWS RISING ARE HEADING UP
THANK YOU MISTER TRAVIS WANNA
REITERATE- THE SUPPORT FOR OUR
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY OUT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS THEY
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD- AND
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN WE
STARTED OFF IT WAS FIVE HUNDRED
BOYS ARE LESS NOW WE'RE AT
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS
AND I THINK THE- STAFF IN THE
PRESENTERS FOR BRINGING BACK
THAT INFORMATION ON THE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE IMPACT THAT'S
THERE. CERTAINLY WE ALSO WANT
TO SPEAK UP FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE GONE OUT
OF BUSINESS DURING COVERT
NINETEEN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY IN THIS BODY TO MAKE
SURE ALL EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- I HAVE A SAFE
AND SECURE PLACE TO WORK BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A PLACE FOR THEM TO
WORK AND SUPPORTING OUR
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MR JEFF. THANK YOU. OKAY
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE I'M GOING TO GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT- I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY IN THE GALLERIES ARE
MADE IN THE GALLERY. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN THE
GALLERY BUT I WILL GO TO THE
OPERATOR OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE.
WISH TO ASK A QUESTION OR
PROVIDE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
ASSIST YOU OFFLINE THEY WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND WHEN YOU HEAR THE
ALARM NUMBER CALLED YOUR LINE
WILL BE OPEN AGAIN THAT IS. ONE
ZERO. AND WARMONGER SPEAKERS WE
DO HAVE TO SPEND SHOWING UP.
APPARATUS COMMITTEE QUEUING UP.
OPERATOR WE DO HAVE A FEW
PEOPLE WE WILL GO TO LINE
NINETEEN LINE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER SINISTER
BRAMBLE SPEAKING THIS MORNING
ON BEHALF OF THE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION JUST URGING THE
SUPPORT FOR THE PAID SICK LEAVE
PROPOSAL. SENATE BILL NINETY
FIVE QUICK QUICK PERSONAL
ANECDOTE MY HOUSEHOLD
CONTRACTED COVERT NINETEEN AND
CAME OUT ON THE OTHER SIDE
THANKFULLY- I'M LUCKY TO BE
ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME BUT MY
WIFE WORKS IN THE PAYROLL
OFFICE AT THE ELK GROVE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. WORKERS NEED
THEIR PAYCHECKS EVEN DURING
THIS GLOBAL PANDEMIC SO SHE
MUST REPORT TO WORK WHEN THE
FIRST MEMBER OF OUR HOUSEHOLD
MY DAUGHTER TESTED POSITIVE IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR. MY WIFE
WAS QUARANTINED AND SPENT A
WEEK TAKING CARE OF HER BEFORE
TESTING POSITIVE HERSELF
BELIEVE THAT SHE TOOK DURING
THESE TWO QUARANTINES TOTALLY
WIPED OUT HER CREEK LEAVES. AND
SHE WONDERS WHAT HAPPENS NOW
SHE GETS SICK STAYING HOME
GREATLY LIMITED THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS OUTSIDE OF OUR
HOUSEHOLD BUT THIS BILL. SENATE
BILL NINETY FIVE ACKNOWLEDGES
THE IMPACT OF THIS WIDESPREAD
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ON
FAMILIES LIKE MINE AND PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FOR ALL
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
BIGGER OPERATOR WE WILL NOW GO
TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN. BY TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ACTUALLY HOW
CAN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE WANT TO TAKE
LEADERSHIP FOR DRAFTING MANY OF
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
CONCERNED ABOUT SB NINETY FIVE
IN THE MARCH TWELFTH AMENDMENT
THAT SPECIALLY THE EXEMPTION
FOR OUR SMALLER. SAYS WE STILL
HOWEVER HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONTINUED PRESSURE EXCUSE
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYER IT IS A
SAFETY NET FOR THE STATE OF THE
NINETEEN RESPONSE ESPECIALLY
THE MACALESTER REGULATION
ALREADY MANDATES THAT ANY
EMPLOYEE WITH KEPCO THE
NINETEEN OR WHO HAS POTENTIALLY
BEEN EXPOSED. MUST BE EXCLUDED
WITH FULL PAY AND BENEFITS FOR
A MINIMUM OF TEN DAYS MOST
CONCERNING IS A PROVISION
MAKING A SWEEP OBLIGATION
RETROACTIVE TO JANUARY FIRST IN
A TIME WHEN EMPLOYERS ARE
CAREFULLY PLANNING HOW THEY
WILL SPEND EVERY PENNY TO
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE AND
ENSURE THEY CAN COVER PAYROLL
AN EMPLOYER COULD BE INUNDATED
WITH REQUESTS TO RETRACT THAT
STATEMENT. WELL THERE ARE SOME
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT MOST OF THE
QUALIFYING REASONS ARE LIMITED
FOR THE GENERAL TAX CREDIT TO
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LAW HAS A FIVE
HUNDRED ELEVEN DOLLARS PER K.
CAP FOR EVERY SINGLE QUALIFYING
RESENT. THE RETROACTIVE
APPLICATION IS ALSO A MASSIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE PART AND IT'S
NOT CLEAR HOW TO RECONCILE THE
SLOT WITH THE SITUATION WHERE
AN EMPLOYEE WAS THAT JANUARY
NEWS PTO SICK LEAVE OR VACATION
AND NOW BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN
LEAVE UNDER THIS LAW ANY ERROR
IN APPLYING MATTER DISPUTE AS
TO HOW MUCH AN EMPLOYEE WOULD
BE- IT IS SUBJECT POSSIBLE
PENALTIES. AND FINALLY WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT LIABILITY
PENALTIES UNDER THE LABOR CODE
ANY EMPLOYEE OR FORMER EMPLOYEE
WHO BELIEVE THEY ARE NOW- TO
RETROACTIVE PAYMENT COULD ALSO
ARGUE THESE TRIGGERS PENALTIES
UNDER THE LABOR CODE WHEN WE
REQUESTED THAT THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SAY THAT EMPLOYER
COULD NOT BE PENALIZED BASED ON
THE RETROACTIVE NATURE THE BELT
THAT REQUEST WAS DENIED.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY LEADS THE
NATION IN COVER NINETEEN
RELATED EMPLOYMENT LAW IT'S AN
EMPLOYER SIMPLY CANNOT TAKE
WORK FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FOR
THAT REASON WE RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE SB NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO LAW
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ALIGN IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WERE DISAPPOINTED IN SOME OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
ADOPTED WE STILL FEEL THAT THIS
IS A MAJOR STEP FORWARD FOR
BOTH. WORKERS WHO'VE BEEN
KEEPING A STATE FUNCTIONING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND BOTH
ARE OVERALL FIGHT TO SLOW THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS AS MANY OF
THE COMMENTERS MENTIONED. THIS
NOT ONLY HELPS TAKE CARE OF
WORKERS WHO CONTRACTED THE
VIRUS BUT ALSO REALLY HELPS
THEM STAY HOME AND NOT SPREAD
THE VIRUS TO THEIR CO WORKERS.
ARE RESPECTED THE POINT ABOUT
COVER NINETEEN ETF THAT DOES
NOT COVER A LOT OF THE
SITUATIONS THAT WILL BE COVERED
BY THIS AND THE WAY THAT THE
BILL IS CONSTRUCTED THERE
SHOULD BE NO PART OF PENALTIES
FOR EMPLOYERS AS LONG AS THEY
DO PROVIDE. THE DIRECTOR
PRODUCTIVE LEAVE THAT WAS
PROPERLY REQUESTED- WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THE BILL ENERGIZED
AT THE. PROPER TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BULAGA THE LINE
TWENTY FOUR LIVE TWENTY FOUR U.
LINES OPEN. THANK YOU CAN
REALLY ROSENBERGER WHATEVER
COMPLAINT INTERNATIONAL UNION I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE REFRIGERATION
INDUSTRY AT A RATE THAT WHILE
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED WITH THAT
AMENDMENTS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AN OCCASIONAL DRIVER WELL MY
OUR WORKERS ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF THIS BILL AND WE ARE IN.
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINES OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTY
BALLOT ON THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. IN STRONG SUPPORT
SB NINETY FIVE. WE WILL NOW GO
TO LINE THIRTY LINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN COULD RODDY
REPRESENTING NFIB WE ARE
OPPOSED TO S. B. NINETY FIVE
AND ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THAT OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVENTEEN LINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING VERTIGO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION- BEHALF
MORE THAN FOR YOUR HOSPITAL IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE BALANCE THE POLICY-
WITH THE ABILITY FOR HOSPITAL
TO CARE FOR PATIENTS ESPECIALLY
IF WE EXPERIENCE ANOTHER
SURGEON KEITH AND- WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL TO
THAT GOAL AS AMENDED. WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO LET THE MEN DID WALL
LINING OUR OTHER CONCERN- WITH
THOSE OF THE CHAMBER THANK YOU-
ABOUT THE LINE THIRTY THREE
LINE THIRTY THREE YEAR LINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHNNY GRANT WHILE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE A FEW W.
ACTIVATE TEMPLE AND I'M
THINKING ON BEHALF OF A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND FRONTLINE
UFCW MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORTER AT THE NINETY
FIVE. WORKERS NEED EMERGENCY
PAID SICK LEAVE OUT NOW MORE
THAN EVER EMERGENCY PAID LEAD
AS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
WORKER BEING ABLE TO STAY HOME
TO PROTECT THEIR CO WORKERS
FROM EXPOSURE ARE HAVING TO GO
TO WORK BECAUSE THEY NEED
INCOME AND PAPA SITUATION TO BE
PAID IN. FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE NINETY
FIVE I LOVE THE ORGANIZATIONS
YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO ATTEND THE
HEARING BUT WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT THIS
INCLUDES THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL D. D. D. I. O.
CHINESE PROGRESSIVE ASSOCIATION
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. LOS ANGELES
BLACK WORKER CENTER SLIGHTLY
CALIFORNIA MARK PD THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATIVE
FOR THE MODEL MAY TRANSIT UNION
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE BOARD B.
R. O. I. NAY THE COMMITTEE FOR
RECOGNITION OF NURSING
ACHIEVEMENT JOB WITHOUT THE SAN
FRANCISCO WAREHOUSE WORKERS
RESOURCE CENTER. HE WALKED
GREENTOWN IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ALLIANCE AND. THE FACT THAT
ACTION NETWORK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WITH NOW BUT SOMEONE
THIRTY ONE LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINES OPEN. SHARE MEMBERS JOHN
LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIELD CONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE I RESPECTFULLY IN A
OPPOSITION IT WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CHAMBER
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE
LIABILITY ISSUES WITH
RETROACTIVITY AND. WE WILL NOW
GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO LINE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER THE ANIMAL
LEGAL FELLOW AT THE LATE AT
WORK A NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES
FREE LEGAL EDUCATION ADVICE AND
ADVOCACY LOW WAGE WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE. THE STAR THE
CAN DEFINITELY COME FROM
HUNDREDS OF WORKING PACKAGE
BACK TO THE NINETEEN WHEN THEY
HAD ACCESS TO PAID SICK LATELY
BEEN ABLE TO STAY HOME AND STOP
THE SPREAD. WHEN THEY HAVE THEY
BOARD INTO AN IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE
TO GO TO WORK AND RESPECTING
COVER NINETEEN OR STAY HOME
INCOMES AND THEIR JOB I'M SURE
YOU WOULD BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
THAT THE THING THAT A POSSIBLE
CHOICE SOME WORKERS HAVE CHOSEN
TO KEEP WORKING. ON JANUARY YOU
WANT THE FEDERAL PAID SICK
LEAVE AN EXTENSION OF EIGHT
PEOPLE AND PAID SICK LEAVE
ENDED WITH MILLIONS OF WORKERS
ONLY THREE PAID SICK DAYS. IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO QUARANTINE CARE
FOR FAMILY OR POSSIBLY RECOVER
FROM THE VACCINATION ARCHON
WILL RECOVER AND WE CAN REOPEN
AND CANNOT REOPEN SAFELY WHILE
THE STICKER BOTH WORKERS ARE
FORCED TO CONTINUE WORKING.
STUDIES DEGREE HAS STABILIZED
INDEPENDENT AND WE NEED THE
STATE TO ACT TO ENSURE THAT
WORKERS TO COMPLY WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTIVE. THAT THE
THREAT OF PUBLIC NINETEEN AND
STILL KEEP THEIR INCOME AND JOB
WE SUPPORT. E. NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. WE WILL NEVER TO LIE
THIRTY FOR. LINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY-
OUR SON I THINK PARTNERSHIP FOR
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER. AND IN
ORDER TO AT SAN JOSE HAVE
PASSED THE NINETEEN ADVERSITY
PAID PARTICULARLY FOR ALL
WORKERS. THANK YOU COULD BUY.
BUT WE WILL NEED TO.
PROTECTIONS X. THE STATE.
URGENTLY PLEASE TRY SUPPORT
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO MORE CALL WAS GOING TO.
THANK YOU NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. SAYING NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK
LOOKING AT THE COMMITTEE HOW TO
SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT. CAN YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
THEN WE WILL ADJOURN BUT WE
HAVE ONE MORE PARTICULAR ONE
MORE PERSON THE QUEUE THANK YOU.
FOUR POINT TWENTY FIVE AIRLINES
OPEN. THIS IS KATIE WATER
CONNECT WITH A CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION- MORE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY FIVE WITH EMERGENCY PAID
SICK LEAVE AND IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO SAVE LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE YOUR I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PHILIPPI WE HAVE ONE MORE CALL
OF ONE OF. HUH CALLER THE FOR
YOUR LINES OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LISA AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE JEWISH CENTER FOR
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BECAUSE WE MUST. YOU
THIS BILL TO GET PAID SICK
LEAVE AND STOP THE SPREAD OF
CODED NINETEEN WE BELIEVE THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY A MORAL ISSUE AND
WE MUST PASS THIS BILL SO WE
ARE HOPING FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NO LOCAL
AGENT YOU. OPERATED MORE COLORS.
NO MORE COLLEGE GRADUATE THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU. SINGLE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THEN I WILL MOVE
TO JERK THANK YOU.